ladies and gentlemen Creator executive
producer and showrunner Matt
Walbert and then someone with a Sim
similar Creator executive producer and
showrunner Ben
nadvi I hope I pronounced that right
Ben executive producer Merill
Davis Creator executive producer
showrunner Ronald D
Moore and then perhaps some actors you
guys are familiar with we have Ren
Schmidt we have Chris
Marshall and then I believe we have
someone named Joel
kinman
looking so young your
fresh we'll hug later
yeah uh I have a ton of questions uh but
first I really want to uh point out to
you guys uh so please raise your hand if
you got on a plane to come
here
right or if you drove really far did you
drive really anyone Drive really far oh
I see some hands thank you so much for
coming uh I'm so I really want to give a
huge thank you to Apple TV Plus for
partnering up for you guys for all
coming here tonight uh as everyone knows
I love this show it's one of the best
things on TV I'm I'm thrilled that
everyone got to see it on a movie screen
tonight and uh I remember please no like
live streaming or spoiling this for
people who have not been able to see the
finale we would hate to do that um so I
got a few questions here we go uh in
what season might and Ron might have
heard this one and maybe perhaps uh and
what season are we going to get a
Starship you want to take that one R oh
it's
coming but we're not going to give that
away we we need many more seasons out of
apple so it might be a while uh I am
curious is it possible that For All
Mankind is the prequel show to the
eventual Star Trek type show on Apple TV
that takes place like a 100 or 200 years
later and this is like how we've gotten
there so it's like do you see where I'm
going with that uh I'm happy to announce
the the that Apple has ordered many
series from all of us no thank you Steve
keep pushing I'm going to keep uh by the
way I'm going to keep going on this uh I
put on uh on social media that I was
going to be doing this tonight and
something that actually a lot of people
kept asking is and I I really mean this
what Star Trek series exist in the For
All Mankind universe
this I'm actually not joking a lot of
people ask this somebody just asked me
that recently because I guess we there
was an episode uh that just aired uh
where uh we said specifically There Were
Three Star Trek shows and I think and
you guys correct me the last I counted I
thought we were saying it was the
original series Star Trek phase 2 which
was the show that never happened in the
70s and then next generation and that
was our accounting that's right that's
right David
wed
I would imagine how many people actually
for all of you like uh come up to you
and talk to you like like a Jeff Bezos
or an Elon or like NASA people like this
has to be something that all the people
who are interested in space travel on
this planet are watching so have you
heard from any of these people do you
hear that they're watching it I don't
know why Jeff Bezos isn't coming over to
our houses every day and asking s boxes
so I I check my my inbox every morning
but there's no emails from Jeff Bezos or
Elon Musk in them but but we have heard
that a lot of people at Nasa and we just
heard today like people at Issa and
other space agencies are huge fans of
the show and uh honestly it's really
gratifying to hear that they're enjoying
it you guys have talked about how you
have a six or seven season plan or an
idea uh which is what you pitched so I'm
curious um how can you give some
examples of how the show has taken turns
that you didn't actually expect in that
original uh outline if at all
or is it all going according to plan I
will say it's weird from the beginning I
mean one thing we all talked about and I
know the guys talked about when they
were cing this was that Ellen was going
to be president I mean that I was kind
of surprised stayed because something
sometimes when you're talking about
things in the beginning things like that
kind of Fall by the wayside so actually
I have to say from the original plans
that Matt Ben and Ron kind of we're
talking about it's kind of stayed to
plan yeah no it's interesting I think a
lot of the big moves have have have
stayed pretty much as is but like for
example I think originally Molly cob was
slated to ding a fiery plane crash in
episode 106 and we were like we can't do
we cannot do this is too good a
character so we there are definitely
moments where we adjust uh when we're
seeing something good is happening was
asteroid mining part of the plan even
back way back when yes it was
um everything was planned when we were
kids we dreamed this crazy show and it's
amazing it's all no I mean
I think that road map you know it was
really early days and I think we knew
Jean CR gives this speech actually in
episode one that really lays out that
map that we kind of laid out in our
minds and you know it's we've tried to
hold to it but at the same time we allow
ourselves some you know some leeway with
what we're seeing is working or not
working but yeah this season I think the
asteroid belt reaching these asteroids
and Mining them and being able to
maneuver them was such a you know when
we found out what is possible and even
reaching a point now where you're seeing
this happening in our real life like
people are really dealing with asteroids
and so it was exciting to finally catch
up to kind of what's happening right now
with science and it was definitely one
of those Seasons that that kind of stood
out as something we're looking forward
to to kind of doing was it wasn't NASA
like celebrating that they just like
crashed into an asteroid I I thought
that was a little underwhelming they
just like crashed into
it they could have done little better
than that right it was uh this is
actually for the cast you guys have been
with the show since the beginning and
I'm curious how much were you told
before it started filming about the
ultimate arcs that of the characters
that you play um well it it's pretty
close to uh I think we we in our first
conversation we did talk about like a a
five uh season Arc I didn't have a deal
for five season Arc but uh we were very
aware of
that but um uh but yeah and this sort of
it for me it's like kind of uh
astonishing how how much of that initial
conversation that we had has actually
you know come into play like the the the
original vision for the show is I mean
like you know there are little things
I'm sure that that changed as you
mentioned before but it's like pretty
close to that conversation which is kind
of crazy and I was the exact opposite um
I was only slated to do three episodes
in season 1 um I yeah that's it that's
it you want to talk about not having a
deal in place I didn't have a deal in
place and like the little uh hanger on
that I am I just hung in there I clawed
my way like who's on that
asteroid you can't get rid of
me they they applauded when you were
alive I was like that was good
uh I I didn't know where it was going
but I was very clear with Matt and Ben
and Ron and Marl was like I don't want
to know anything just I want I'd love to
see the scripts when they're ready so
was it for I want to continue with you
guys uh what was it like at one of the
things that I love is that about each
season is you're progressing in these
people's lives and for all for the three
of you what is it like getting to play
characters where you actually are
experiencing their lives and also with
this season playing much older versions
and inhabiting that and having to do
that yeah
yeah um I mean it was you know that was
the the really like fascinating acting
challenge with this job and uh and it
was a little frustrating in like season
one and
two because it doesn't really start to
come into play I felt like you know in
the season 3 then you really start to
see the aging and it becomes something
that you get to start to play with but
then in in season 4 then you know that's
when when you really get to the to the
juicy part of it um I mean I hadn't I
knew it was going to be a [__] but I
didn't uh I didn't understand that you
know I was going to have a one a.m. call
time and then have someone just stabbing
in my eye for 6 hours in the morning and
then have a 13 hour workday uh for six
months so that that was that was
definitely a challenge but but it's uh I
mean it's really fascinating to get to
play these ages especially in in a
series cuz you know usually when you
play this you know this much
older um as an actor it's usually in a
sort of epilogue scene of a movie but to
do it you know in a for a whole season
and for seasons of a show you really get
to do this die someone wants me to shut
up um
you know you really get to spend time
with the with the idea of of being at
that age and what aging is and and you
know what it does to you what it does to
your confidence what it you know and
it's fascinating and it it it's it
really goes to the core of what I love
about what we do is like when we we get
to play these different roles we get to
try out these different uh you know
leather human leather suits and um
and you get more empathy for for people
around you and and more understanding
because you just spend that much time
thinking about it so so yeah so that was
has been a huge gift with with this
experience it was such a privilege to
get to play over that period of time but
what was
interesting at least on my end was this
season felt in a way like starting over
you know whereas in the past it had
always been NASA but NASA like stepped
two or three or four and this year I
like honestly when we were starting I
was terrified like I've never been so
terrified in my career of how do you
take on
62 in Russia speaking Russian how has
she changed she doesn't have the same
like it was just literally felt like
other than kind of like the essential
core of who this person was everything
else was different um and trying to
figure out how to navigate that and over
the course of 6 months I mean there were
just days where it was really hard not
to let the actual Terror of that take
over me but I also think in some ways
the fact that there was so much there
was just a certain point which I was
like you just got to stop thinking about
it and just do every day just do so I
don't know I felt like the first three
seasons in a way it was about how the
relationships had changed and the
confidence that comes with Rising
through the ranks and this season I
literally was just like holy
[__] I don't you guys felt that but
that's what I felt this year yeah I I I
think you need to you know continue to
take jobs that scare you this much
because that's what that's you
know um for me I haven't um you know
Danielle was always the youngest of the
the ascan group and so in in last few
seasons she was in her 30s and 40s and
this year she's in her 50s so there
wasn't as much of the physicality that
um that Joel and ren had to go through
especially with the makeup and things
like that um but what I did find really
freeing is that oh man you know it is
tough and also really boring to be an
actress in Hollywood and feel like you
have to stick with all of those like is
she skinny is she pretty does she have
Fine Lines or wrinkles all those sort of
things and it's exciting to play a
character who does have lines in her
face and does have wisdom in her eyes
what you got to say cuz I can see I was
just did she had she had yeah yeah you
got okay was makeup of course but she
didn't yeah the Aging was not a
challenge working with Joel was my
challenge um I'm kidding I love you so
much um but uh yeah so it's fun to have
the sort of shackles of that boredom be
off and just be able to play and have
this woman who's uh Acumen for business
and her intellect for Science and her
inquisitive mind like these are the
reasons why she's in the room not
because she's youthful or beautiful so
um getting to tell Danielle's story for
the last four decades has just been a
treat and like these guys said it's not
the sort of thing that you come across
in television and it's just like just so
delicious like what a Joy so obviously a
lot of us uh we love the the way science
is depicted on the series and I'm
curious in the writing process are you
sort of like how does it actually work
in the writer's room and coming up with
these ideas are you sort of like doing
the story and then like working out the
science later or like how does this you
know equation work how does it work yeah
I'm still trying to figure that out
honestly no we we um always try to have
a very open uh blue sky approach to
brainstorming and so often what we'll do
is we'll come up with what we think is a
really cool and really scientifically
accurate idea and then our advisers will
tell us how there are things like the
laws of physics and and things like that
that that prevent that from happening
and so but then we have a conversation
and so things like the duct tape suit
come out of that conversation because we
were like well can't somebody just go
out on the surface of the Moon and like
run for a minute and he's like no
they would balloon up in like 2 seconds
and die and we're like okay well how
then how could they go outside if they
don't have a space suit and so that
process well if they had to make
something a suit from stuff in that room
and so it was it that's the fun of this
is being creative with people who know a
lot more than we do uh and um
discovering things as we go one of the
things I'm curious about is what I love
is watching them figure out how to solve
a solute like solve something so for
example in the finale when they are out
on the ship and you know the thing the I
forget the name of the device but when
they're pulling the yellow and the black
thing uh like talk a little bit about
coming up with these dilemmas they have
to get through and working out like you
know what I mean coming up with the the
stuff that keeps the audience going yeah
it's it's uh you know we we try to
because Ben and I are are fairly
simple-minded people really speak for
yourself okay well I think I think you
know there's
experience but there's something about
like a switch has to be in or out and
there's all this other complicated stuff
around it but like everybody can
understand that you know and and but
there's drama in that or like
something's getting closer to the line
and so I think we try to build things
around you know complicated situations
that brilliant people have to solve but
at their heart there's this really
dramatic simple idea behind it I think a
little bit yeah I mean what happened
this year which was interesting you know
the show started in the 70s and you know
our our researchers they were basing
things that were that were developed or
real science whereas we're getting as
the show continues we're dealing with
more theoretical ideas so we found
ourselves many times where you know the
writers we argue all the time but now
the our Tech advisers were arguing with
each other as well over like what could
it be because you know I think that's
where the show is going it becomes more
science fiction and I think that
challeng is keeping that ground the
grounded nature of the show in a world
that's less and less familiar hence
Starships just just saying so I am
curious and I'm not sure who wants to
answer this one over the Four Seasons
for each person that wants to answer uh
what has been the most challenging scene
or sequence to pull off in whatever
episode whatever season I'll go first
um the [__] you scene in episode 405
with Danielle and Ed um I wouldn't say I
don't know if challenging is the right
word but it was just it was one of those
dates where I felt like it required
every iota of energy in me to do it um
I've said it before and I'll say it
again like Joel is just so much fun to
work with you really are um that was not
what I thought you were going to
say yeah no it's true and I think that
um you know you can't do this alone you
can try to do it alone and you'll be bad
at it but it's better if you do it
together and and there's only so much
that you can prepare and rehearse and
you know you do your work at home but
then you have to come into the space and
just play with the person who's across
from you and um that day was a long day
it was a taxing day um I mean there are
times when I was so tearful the neck of
my shirt was wet and then other times
where it's like you just do a version
that's really subtle and muted and you
feel like there's nothing there and
there's just so many iterations of that
scene that could have played and could
have lived and um that was really
challenging in the best way and I'm just
I feel really proud of that work that we
did that day yeah I mean I uh that was
probably one of my favorite scenes of
the season but definitely not the
hardest um to me it's it's hard when
it's like not really working and and I
was working that
um um so it wasn't working who can I
throw under the
bus um
I don't know I don't really remember
well
difficult I I don't know it was we'll
pass over you to pretty easy yeah
everything was easy I mean the the
challenge was more you know in the
morning it was it was challenging to not
just yell at everyone all the time cuz
like just going around like spending 18
hours in this like Silicon coffin in
your like your your face is in a coffin
of silicon and then every second someone
is poking you in the eye like it's oh my
God it's like if I hadn't like found
meditation before the season it would
have it would probably be my last season
in my career cuz I would have done
something really bad it was very hard M
saying you want to do it again so you're
saying you're going to sign up again
what's that you want to do it again oh
yeah
yeah all the reality of that just da on
me some somewhere out there in the great
beyond Michael Dorne is
laughing
laughing he's like sipping a glass of
wine in Australia somewhere is so
happy I think it would be like a tossup
between um so the scene in well the
scenes in episode 6 in the um storage
room that was just me by myself with a
couple of blank monitors and our crew so
that was like both really challenging
and also kind of fun to figure out like
how do you navigate that so many pages
where you're not actually getting to
react to much it's just somebody it's it
was Brian Brian was reading with me
Brian raia um so that was both difficult
and fun uh and then I just feel like the
whole Bulgaria shoot of it all we shot
for bulgar in Bulgaria for three and a
half weeks and I've just never had that
many scenes back to back to back to back
where it's just all day almost every day
so that was really challenging for me
because the thing that's nice I well
depending on what your preference is is
in our show we have an ensemble so
everything's kind of split and you might
have like a couple of hard weeks if
you're heavy in that episode but usually
you can take a break and that was just
like a Sprint I mean it was like a a
Nutty Nutty Sprint um but it was really
really great that we had spet Lana um
OVA on our team and we had these six
incredible uh crew members that came
with us and then Matt and Ben and yeah
it was actually a lot of fun in the end
but still I don't know that's not like a
sexy answer but yeah uh I would say like
the most challenging and one of the most
rewarding times on the show was working
out the season 2 finale because it was
there were so many moving pieces you
know you had missiles flying you had the
Soviets and the Americans going to the
brink of nuclear war you had people
shooting each other on the moon base you
had people running around in Duck suits
on the moon Sally rides about to shoot
at Baldwin in the head on the space
shuttle and it was trying to figure out
the rhythm of that and the timing of
that and both on the page and an
editorial and it was like it was very
intense and it was a lot of things to
keep moving and to make it flow in a
dramatic way where you kept holding your
breath and then like oh oh No and then
something else would happen getting to
what the finale actually what it was and
when it all came together I just thought
it was a beautiful beautiful piece of
Television I mean it's kind of hard I
mean when you look at all of the seasons
I mean I just I always kind of go to the
space suits and and the gravity issues
and and certainly in the first SE few
season or couple Seasons I think that
was the most challenging I think the
actors could probably speak more to that
about the space suits and their lovely
feelings about it um well especially the
season 3 Teletubbies uh it was very hard
to take each other seriously while
sitting around and like we're all a
bunch of
Teletubbies I think the space suits this
season though Esther our costume
designer um created an amazing suit this
season and what was interesting about it
kind of to what Ben was saying is
beforehand we always kind of were basing
things off prototypes or things maybe
NASA was thinking about but didn't use
but then this season it was kind of just
kind of what are we going to do because
there wasn't a prototype um so I think
Esther created an amazing suit um with
mat and Ben's input obviously and I
think the actors are probably happier
this season yeah um yeah the the season
one was was that was gruesome yeah I
mean those were were 70b yeah that's
really really heavy with the boots and
the helmet 70 pounds so it's heavy yeah
poor
us poor actors actors really
suffer solidarity Ben and I wore space
suits every day that they had to wear
space SU to set while we were sitting in
our director's chairs do you guys want
to uh touch on anything that was
difficult you want me to ask you we
don't complain we enjoy we are you're
living our dream all been Bliss and
that's what we absolute Bliss every day
is a
gift well I I want to ask some specific
stuff which I please do not put online
until after tomorrow night and we're
filming again uh but I want to talk
about the way the season 4 ends and that
I love that shot of you know Eddie on
the on the surface and pulls back and
then eventually it pull in 2012 and that
whole thing is A+ so talk a little bit
about how long it took to come up with
that shot and how you wanted the season
to end I mean it was really tricky I
think we you know there was so many dark
things that happened over the course of
that episode and so we kind of wanted to
end on this note of hopefulness and
idealism and sort of you know devb is
seeing the fruition of of what he he and
his team worked uh uh so hard to bring
to reality but it's also what um you
know what Margot talks about in the
viewing Gallery it's it's um that is
that symbolizes the future of the space
program and the fact that they have
committed to building out those um
mining facilities it's just a symbol of
how much the world is going to change
going forward uh and so I think that's a
really exciting possibility for the
future of the series I want to do a
followup if you don't mind I love that I
was studying that the the mining things
on the asteroid I've watched it like
three or four times just that shot and
it looks the best the way we all saw it
tonight is there anything for fans they
should look for in that mining shot with
the cranes moving and everything else oh
you're talking about a little Easter egg
aren't you yeah I I'm just curious if
people should look for anything well I
don't if you want to look you can
look there may be something there I
won't commit to it but but uh yeah yeah
just if you squint real
hard uh I listen I know that uh if
hypothetically you are able to get
another season how much is that last
shot with those mining things on the
asteroid how much is that a major thing
if you get to continue the show you know
there's always those flash forwards we
do it's funny because as much as we plan
okay this is what we don't really know
what the next season's going to be so a
lot of times we end up having to back
into that shot um in many ways so but in
this way we did feel we knew a little
bit about where we want the show to go
with that road map and I think that last
shot conveys really what Matt was saying
I mean how amazing it is the road this
show has been on and this alt history
that we've reached a point where this
colony of hundreds will now become a
colony potentially of thousands and that
this asterid allows that to happen it
allows us to not only colonize Mars but
go even further and I think that's
really the the beauty of that shot in
the symbolism of of what it represents
but where are are the
aliens Joel has been obsessed with
aliens I'm not kidding you since one he
comes to say every time he's like I mean
is it too it's too early I feel like
it's Joel it's not this show the answer
is no yeah
Starship with aliens in
it I I am curious for the cast and for
for everyone else this is a very
emotional season filled of ups and downs
and I'm curious what it was like reading
those scripts for the first time and
seeing what was going to happen
especially in the finale like I loved
hearing the audience here you could hear
them and then reacting to when they saw
you um you know survive like there's a
anyway I'm just curious if you guys
could talk about the scripts because
this season was fantastic um I think
part of the really cool concept of
jumping ahead and decades each season is
that it means that we get to know these
folks for a whole lot longer and I think
that you know I think about that moment
in season 3 when you and I in The
Outpost and you've been given the
command and then it's taken from you and
then I've been given the command and
there's a sort of back and forth and
there's the top text of this command but
then beneath that is the subtext of
someone who was once the Junior and he
was a superior and you know he was the
one that I learned from and now at later
on we become sort of uh even Steven and
then later as you see in season 4 we
become adversaries in many ways and we
can't earn that in normal time we can't
earn that in a single season you can't
earn that in six months or in six years
you earn that kind of payoff in this
relationship between these two people
and so when we see in the midst of this
Riot Ed and Danielle see one another and
there's this camaraderie of like I don't
care what we've been through the two of
us are in in Peril and we got to stick
together it's just it's you can't put a
you can't put a name to it it doesn't
exist in traditional storytelling and
that's been fun and really cool and it
can't I have not seen it done in other
TV shows I feel like again I'm kind of
[__] for answering this question because
my season was so different from theirs
it was like Margot was in timeout like
timeout timeout timeout but I actually
had a realization tonight watching the
episode um which was as Margo's being
led out of NASA I just thought out of
nowhere she's free now yeah she's
finally free I mean of course we know
she's going going into a cage but you
know what has been built up for the past
three seasons I just had this moment of
relief for her of but I didn't I didn't
necessarily see that in the script I saw
it in the all of the components of our
show coming together the you know the
scripts going to you know all the way to
being on set and then you know the sound
that gets added in and I don't know
really I feel like was the culmination
of all of the pieces together and total
sidebar
Jay and Barbara who do our VFX are so
legitimately incredible that and seeing
your work up here is just amazing
amazing stand up the asteroid stuff and
the ships those two
yeah I I have to ask at at any point
when you guys were writing the finale
did someone who was working on it say
how the f are we going to film this the
director did yeah and honestly as we
were writing it we were like how the f
are we going to pull this off and he and
just watching I'm like how the F did we
pull that off it's in it's insane it's
an insane episode TV but it's great I
mean it's it's amazing uh it's a lot now
we dread the finales because we know
it's coming we just know I mean the
buildup like Ron was saying about season
two but I feel like every finale has
kind of been you know all the threads of
the season come together and I feel like
at the end we're left with we're like
okay we've got to bring this together
and and you know like Ren said it's
interesting I I do feel it's that moment
where everyone comes together not just
the writers but I feel like the actors
the the the the music the visual effects
it's really it feels like the entire
crew comes together for that finale in a
way every season and so while this was
terrifying in many ways when we looked
at what we had to finish I feel like by
this season we feel like okay we we're
going to get there I was going to
something else though is you obviously
every show is made on a budget and you
have um some big moments during the
season so how do you figure out where
and when you want to deploy the added
resour the the the big resources like
big VFX shots or big action or whatever
it may be because you have the you know
the 10 episodes to like where and when
to deploy those assets Seth edstein you
want to stand
up our line producer up there who is a
huge huge part of making the show a
reality and is amazing
partner and it's and it is you know one
of those ongoing discussions of just
like do we want to start big and then
kind of you know suck away our dollars
sort of for the ending we always know
the ending needs to be big so we just
have to kind of I think one of our goals
is to try to make each season feel
different in the in the like the flow of
the story so we don't want everyone to
be expected in terms of how the the epic
moments come about uh we're we're just
about out of time I've already been
given the wrap up but I'm pushing a
little more and hopefully they don't
hook me but I'm I'm just curious for the
cast is it fun playing someone that you
completely disagree with when they're
doing something or do you enjoy like
relish when you are getting to play
someone that you strongly disagree with
oh I I I love when Ed is a terrible
dad those my favorite
scenes and even when he's a terrible
Granddad oh I love
it so
fun yeah it's it's frustrating I mean
Matt and Ben can tell you I wrote a
strongly worded email in season 3 when
Danielle basically says to will Tyler
like don't be gay now um it was awful it
was so awful and I was so frustrated
because I've grown to know and love and
feel like I am Danielle and for her to
um stand against him and reprimand him
for coming out it just infuriated me and
I wrote them an email and said I'm not
going to do it this is not what Danielle
would do and you you're wrong I'm right
so fix it and they were like cool beans
no um and made me do it anyway and I am
so glad they did because it ended up
being really beautiful you know real
people sometimes do the wrong thing they
do the wrong thing all the time and that
is what makes her a human being and not
just a character on the page so yeah all
the time I disagree with
Danielle I think actually something that
Matt said to me when we were I can't
remember if we were filming or if it was
a meeting but he he was talking about
like the push pull of when you get to
like the place of having work together
for a while and you know you don't
always necessarily see eye to eye but
there's actually sometimes something
really interesting that comes from the I
don't know like the debate or kind of
the like that friction of being asked to
do something that you don't think is is
right and those are honestly some of my
favorite moments in the season I mean
just to give you guys a little clue as
to what I'm referencing in the elevator
when Margot and sergey's fingers kind of
intertwin that came from that friction
cuz I was like she'd never risk it all
for a snog in the elevator she would
never do
uh and I actually think that that's like
one of the most beautiful moments in
that relationship because I don't know
it was
just there was just so much to it and I
never would have come up with that on my
own I feel like that was because we had
like a conversation about it and some
Push
Pull said this is my last thing my last
uh because again I've I've been given
the wrap-up signal like 16 times um for
this this a audience is filled with
diard fans of the series so I'm curious
B
right so I'm curious for whoever wants
to answer what do you think super fans
of the show would be surprised to learn
about the making of the
show it is a it's a curveball but here
we
go I'm not
answering I mean obviously that Joel
hates being in makeup I think we've
learned
that just prosthetic makeup that's
that's the only other makeup I
love I mean I think it's sort of back to
what what um I was talking about before
with Molly there are there are these
moments where that just come out of
these these brainstorming sessions like
you know um Gordo and Tracy uh were a
part of the show Beyond season 2 in our
original
conversations and we we kind of actually
in the middle of that season we sort of
came up with this concept of what if
Gordo goes back to the goes to the moon
to get his wife back and it was like
this
romantic gesture and that led to this
idea of of this tragic but insanely
romantic death and we did not want to do
it in any way because we loved those
actors and those characters and we knew
that because our reaction was that way
that it was the right thing to do and so
that's something that I think you know
there are a lot of scenes that we talked
about in the early days of the writers
room with Gordo and Tracy in in this
world that that because we came up with
this interesting idea that was so
powerful uh those scenes you know are
now in The Ether of of the world I was
just going to say you asking Steve
what's something that folks don't know
yeah like you know cool behind the
scenes and this is again maybe like a
cheating answer but I think what folks
know but I think it's important is that
we all really do enjoy each other um I
think you know Ron has said many times
and I'm going to mess up this quote but
something to the effect of like that the
showrunner is the first among equals and
that Doctrine has bled into every single
thing we do for the last six years of
making this show and so whether it's
like you know collaboration on set or
conversations in fittings like we all
really enjoy each other's company we
really get on well and I feel like it
translates from the room through the
show into the audience I see like the
folks on the Reddit forums and the
conversations and they have their
communities and their connections
together and it just it feels so Kum by
to say but it feels like a family and I
think that that's cool don't you [__]
laugh when I'm saying about our family
you have family on Thanksgiving yeah you
see what I have to deal
with on that note I just want to point
out that there's this thing called
social media and if you enjoy the show
please talk about it online spread the
love ladies and gentlemen a huge thank
you to Apple TV Plus for letting us do
this to the cast and creators thank
thank you so much for coming out guys we
really really appreciate you guys for
coming thank you thank you
[Applause]
guys